This is your brain. Yay. I'm your brain.
I have a lot of good ideas and stuff.
This is your brain on
Da. Durr. I don't know what to believe
about anything because God might be
tricking me about everything. And God is
the best deceiver ever. Dur.
Alhamdulillah. Any questions? In case
you'd like proof of what DA does to your
brain, let's go through Sajid Lipam's
borderline insane response to Wes Huff.
As you may know, Wes Huff appeared on
Pierce Morgan Live and he drew attention
to a historical blunder in the Quran.
Oh, I think the Quran has a number of of
problematic historical issues. A chief
of which is that um Surah 4157 denies
the historical crucifixion of Jesus. And
so, uh, there's ambiguity as to what's
going on in that text when it says that
Jesus was neither killed nor was he
crucified. And I think that really
paints the the historical reliability of
the Quran into a corner. What's the
historical blunder? Surah 47 denies the
historical crucifixion of Jesus. Surah 4
verse 157 of the Quran denies the
historical crucifixion of Jesus. Let's
read the verse. That they said in boast.
They here are a group of Jews who were
boasting. That they said in boast, "We
killed Christ Jesus, the son of Mary,
the apostle of God." But they killed him
not nor crucified him, but so it was
made to appear to them. And those who
differ therein are full of doubts with
no certain knowledge, but only
conjecture to follow. For of assurityity
they killed him not.
What does this mean? Well, according to
the traditional Muslim view, Jesus went
around telling people to believe in God
and in the Torah. For some strange
reason, this upset the Jews who believed
in God and in the Torah so much that
they decided to kill him. But God had a
plan. When they came for Jesus, God took
Jesus out of this world into heaven and
miraculously disguised someone else to
make him look like Jesus. And it was
this other person who was crucified. But
God through the power of illusion and
deception made everyone think that it
was Jesus. So most Muslims are convinced
that Surah 4:157 of the Quran denies the
historical crucifixion of Jesus. And Wes
goes on to point out that Jesus death by
crucifixion isn't just a Christian
belief that non-Christian historians
would reject because they're not
Christians. On the contrary, even
non-Christian historians consider Jesus'
death by crucifixion to be a fact of
history. Like I said before, Pierce, if
there's one thing that even the most
skeptical scholars historically uh will
say, you know, if they say we really can
know not that much about Jesus of
Nazareth, they will admit and say what
we can know is that he did die under the
the reign of of Pontius Pilate, the
governor of Judea at that time that he
was indeed crucified. Did you detect any
deception from Wes Huff? I didn't, but
Sajid Lipam did. And Sajid blasts Wes
for deceiving his viewers. Even though,
oddly enough, Sajid has no problem
whatsoever with God deceiving literally
billions of people by tricking us into
believing that Jesus died by
crucifixion. Let's go through Sajid's
response right after a brief word about
this video's sponsor. Suppose you run
into Sajid Lipum one day and you share
the gospel with him. Since Sajid
believes that God is a deceiver who
tricks people into believing false
things for no apparent reason, Sajid is
going to reject your claim that Jesus
died on the cross. But suppose he takes
this a step further. Suppose he says,
"There is no land of the Bible. God just
tricked you and made you think that
there's a land of the Bible." What do
you do? Well, if you've joined Artsa,
you've got nothing to worry about. Artza
gathers products from local artisans in
Jerusalem and Nazareth and Bethlehem and
other locations and ships them to you in
a box. You get candles, Israeli spice
mixes, olivewood carvings, mosaic art,
decorations, cosmetics, candy, games,
all kinds of things. Every box you buy
connects you with the land of the Bible
and supports local families and
charities and small businesses in
Israel. There's a new box every 3
months. They're fun to open with your
family and they make great gifts. If you
haven't signed up to receive your
quarterly arts box, the link is in the
description. Use the promo code dizzle
to get a discount and to let them know
who sent you. Now, let's see how our
friend Saget responds to the
indisputable, factually correct claims
of Wes Huff about Jesus crucifixion and
the Quran. He makes it appear as if
Allah in the Quran is unaware that
people believe Jesus was crucified.
Meanwhile, arguing that even historians
who might question all sorts of
different things about the life of
Jesus, even they believe that there is
strong evidence that Jesus was
crucified. Liar. At no point did Wes
suggest that the Quran isn't aware of
the fact that people believed Jesus died
by crucifixion. He simply said that the
Quran denies the historical crucifixion
of Jesus. Surah 4157 denies the
historical crucifixion of Jesus. But
Sajid isn't going to disagree with Wes
on that. So he has to pretend that Wes
is misleading people and implying that
the author of the Quran has no idea that
people believed Jesus was crucified.
After Sajid blatantly misrepresents Wes,
he goes on to attack the straw man he
made. Whereas the reality is the exact
same verse that he is referencing
confirms that yes, the people did think
that he was crucified. It affirms that
yes, it was made to seem as though Jesus
was crucified. Wes didn't pretend the
Quran claims that people didn't believe
Jesus was crucified. He criticized the
Quran for denying the historical reality
of the crucifixion. So why isn't Sajid
refuting what Wes actually said because
Sajid knows how silly he sounds when he
tells people that God tricked billions
of people into believing something that
never happened. But by all means, Sajid,
continue refuting your straw man. So
this is the verse that he literally
mentions by name. It mentions how many
Israel was boasting saying, "We killed
the Messiah, Jesus, son of Mary, the
messenger of Allah." But they neither
killed him nor crucified him. It was
only made to appear so. It was only made
to appear to them that Jesus was
crucified. So according to Sajid, the
Quran is denying the historical reality
of the crucifixion, which is exactly
what Wes said. So just think if Wes Huff
and the Christians who are praising his
appearance on Piers Morgan literally
completely misrepresented a verse as
simple as this. Imagine the extent that
some of them will go to misrepresent
other verses of the Quran, other
teachings of the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Think about
the irony here. Sajid accuses Wes Huff
of misrepresenting the Quran when he's
misrepresenting what Wes said. He's
accusing Wes of deceiving people about
the Quran when according to Sajid, God
deceived billions of people about Jesus.
And again, it's not just billions of
Christians who believe that Jesus died
by crucifixion. Even non-Christian
scholars are convinced that Jesus death
by crucifixion is a fact of history.
Atheist New Testament scholar Garrett
Ludman declares that Jesus death as a
consequence of crucifixion is
indisputable. John Dominick Crossen of
the infamous Jesus Seminar says that
there is not the slightest doubt about
the fact of Jesus crucifixion under
Pontius Pilate. Marcus Borg, another
member of the Jesus Seminar, states that
Jesus execution is the most certain fact
about the historical Jesus. Jewish
scholar Pinkis Lee affirms that Jesus
death by crucifixion is historically
certain. According to Paula
Frederickson, a convert to Judaism, the
single most solid fact about Jesus life
is his death. He was executed by the
Roman prefect Pilate on or around
Passover in the manner Rome reserved
particularly for political
insurrectionists, namely crucifixion.
And Bartman maintains one of the most
certain facts of history is that Jesus
was crucified on orders of the Roman
prefect of Judea, Pontius Pilate. These
are non-Christian historians and New
Testament scholars. Jesus death by
crucifixion is an indisputable fact of
history and the Quran according to the
vast majority of Muslims says it never
happened.
Like it or not, that's a problem. But
Sagid shouldn't be attacking Wes Huff
for drawing attention to the problem. In
fact, there's a much easier approach for
Sagid. So, let me speak directly to
Sagid because we all know he's watching.
Sajid, if you don't like something that
someone says or does, you don't need to
attack the person because your theology
provides a completely different way of
dealing with him. Since you believe in a
god who tricks people into believing
things that never happened. Since you
believe in a god who deceives people for
no apparent reason. When you see someone
like Wes Huff sharing information that
you find
embarrassing, why don't you just blame
Allah? Maybe Wes Huff never said
anything to Pierce Morgan. Maybe Allah
simply tricked you into believing that
Wes Huff was on Pierce Morgan. Maybe Wes
Huff doesn't even exist. Allah only
tricked you into believing Wes Huff
exists. What if Pierce Morgan doesn't
even have a show? Allah could be
deceiving all of us whenever we think
we're watching Pierce
Morgan. How do you know Pierce Morgan
even
exists? You believe in an omnipotent
deceiver, right? He could be tricking us
about
everything. Maybe I've never criticized
Islam at all and you've been losing
sleep for all these years over an
illusion from your
God. Maybe Allah is just making everyone
think I'm schooling you right
now. Maybe I'm not here at all.
[Music]